la dixième édition du forum santé est
lancé jusqu'au samedi 14 juin une
vingtaine d'acteurs de la santé vous
accueillent gratuitement au centre
commercial espace saint quentin
parmi les participants l'association
française des diabétiques des yvelines
elle propose aux passants des dépistages
de glycémie gratuit sans fil des saisons
comme ça les étagères comme j'ai jamais
fait c'est juste une remarque je dis
c'était gratuit j'ai dit je vis ici mais
par agissent ils m'ont dit que c'était
bon ou un petit peu rassuré
parallèlement donc là on m'a dit que
c'est bon ça me rassure il suffit d'une
goutte pour savoir la quantité de sucre
contenu dans le sang de la personne
lors de cette première journée les
bénévoles ont dépisté quelques glycémie
élevée
nous avons conseillé aux personnes de
s'orienter très rapidement vers leur
médecin traitant pour pouvoir avoir un
examen plus approfondi entre autres une
glycémie à jeun
à quelques mètres de là le pôle jeunesse
de la ville de montigny le bretonneux
propose notamment deux outils les
lunettes alcool et le testeur du
monoxyde de carbone le premier permet de
se rendre compte de la vision d'une
personne alcoolisée tandis que le
deuxième permet de vérifier si l'on est
dépendant ou non au tabac en soufflant
dans l'embout l'appareil détecte la
quantité de monoxyde de carbone et en
actifs pensez pas trop dépendants et qui
finalement était
borderline on va dire donc ça permet une
petite prise de conscience et aussi avec
les lunettes de se rendre compte que
on se croit toujours maître de la
situation mais en fait on a des réflexes
plus lent on a une vision très très
restreinte donc tout ça ils s'en rendent
bien compte avec ces outils là vous avez
jusqu'à samedi 19h pour profiter de ces
tests gratuits vous informer auprès des
autres participants le forum est
organisé par l'institut de promotion de
la santé de trappes